I love that this guy had such high hopes
to be president United States and now
it's just like him and Kamala that's the
best part of the bite administration
because now everybody that's involved
with him is just the laughing stock
they're such embarrassing human beings
this is how we feel but I feel like the
left might be priming him to run for
president and I'm priming my flight to
leave the country I think it's I think
it's going to be either him or Gavin
news Gavin
newstrom
whatever yeah that's what that was
that's what I meant
um yeah so it's going to be either
either him or Gavin it depends I know
they want to put Gavin up against
DeSantis
because of their personalities and just
and Gavin's always coming after Ron
DeSantis about everything and remember
that whole the Spiel that he did about
how California is the land of the free
remember that the commercial yeah I did
a commercial like a month ago